Archbishop thank you for joining us on
Sky News today now you've launched a
report along with the Archbishop of York
about how we need to think rethink you
say reimagine how we provide care in the
UK and you say in the report there's a
clear Christian vision
for an issue which affects every person
many people might be wondering what a
political issue like this has got to do
with religious leaders like you
I don't think it's a political issue
um it's obviously a political issue
because everything's political but this
is one that's deeply about how we care
for people
how we love our neighbors how we value
people who the world around us doesn't
value very much people who need care
and therefore nothing could be more
ethical more moral or more deeply
embedded in the Christian tradition part
of the earliest part of Christianity
even in the first 30 or 40 Years of
Christianity was that there was this
unusual community that cared equally for
everyone not just for the people who
were strong and Rich an Archbishop
I've read the report and there are many
references to Bible quotations and to
Christ teachings within the report and
and the commission's work in a country
where most people are not Christians
wrapping up these proposals in religious
language do you fear in any way that
that might alienate people some people
it probably may but it would be very
surprising if the church produced a
report that didn't go to the heart of
Christianity
and to the Bible and to say that what
we're putting forward is in very deeply
embedded in the Christian Heritage of
this country even if not in many
people's current belief and and
Archbishop I'm going to get to the
report in a moment but do you feel you
had to come up with this report on
social care because as you actually
write in the report for 25 years
politicians have not grasped the nettle
it's been talked about but it hasn't
been solved we even had a prime minister
in Boris Johnson a few years ago who
promised a plan to fix social care he
announced plans for tax Rises were you
dismayed when that came to nothing
not dismayed but certainly it's
disappointing
though
one has to recognize that politicians
have enormously difficult
questions of priority but this is one of
the most fundamental questions affecting
our country morally and ethically but
also because it has ramifications and
facts all over the country it has
effects on hospitals it has effects on
families it has effects on people who
need care people with learning
difficulties people who are elderly I
mean we all know people who need care
and support many of us help with caring
with people
do you think politicians haven't done a
good enough job in this area
oh
I'm not going to get into that sort of
blame game
um it's not about whether they've done a
good enough job or not we are where we
are what can be done about the future
and what we're trying to do in this
report is not just say something must be
done but to say here are some real ideas
to look at and what is for you the game
changing idea in the report for you the
game-changing idea is what we call in
the report a national Covenant on care
and we all many people will know about
the Armed Forces Covenant Covenant is a
word that is not the same as contract
Covenant is the offering of a commitment
to a person or a group of people without
expecting to get anything back now of
course you do when you care you get a
lot back but the national Covenant of
care is saying
as a nation can we promise people
that they will be cared for
when circumstances turn against them but
you do need to get political leaders on
site to do that that's exactly right and
that's why we've put forward
really solid plans for how this can be
organized and really solid plans for
what it might look like and they some of
them are about what government must do
some about local government some about
families and some about institutions
like the church it's quite critical of
the church as it is about other
institutions to be a bit contrarian
about it it you could argue it's a bit
motherhood and apple pie in the sense
it's I've read it it's hard to disagree
with anything in that report when I
struggled a bit with was how it actually
took us forward
it takes us forward because it tries to
set of values what tends to happen in
government over care is they say we've
got this money for care how are we going
to spend it this turns the thing
entirely the other way around and says
we've got these needs
what does it look like if we meet them
and then says
we now have to work out how to fund that
but I mean you don't go shopping and say
oh I've got a 10 pound note in my pocket
how can I spend it you say I need to get
some milk some bread some
how much do I need to afford to get
these things you you've got to put what
you want to do ahead of how you fund it
but you accept that and I know that you
didn't go into detail you say explicit
in the report I don't want to go into
detail about how to pay for it because a
debate only concerned with funding
misses the point
but you also acknowledge that funding is
a critical issue and you do talk in the
report about the principles of funding
how do you sit on the principle do you
think it should be General taxation do
you think it should be about people
using their personal assets do you think
we should pay more for social care
first of all just to remember when you
say you we're talking you're talking
about the whole church yes and the
Commissioned I didn't write the report I
couldn't have written such a good one
um and it's led by Professor Anna Dixon
with
um years and years and years of
professional experience in this area and
the bishop of Carlisle the same
um
yes there is going to be a significant
cost I mean the the government we're
online with the government uh and the
House of Lords report in uh December
that said we need uh eight billion
pounds as an urgent need and another
seven year by year over time
to start to approach these problems
um they've done the heavy lifting on the
numbers and their numbers seem to make
sense
uh the uh change that was subsequently
abandoned in the um uh national
insurance rate would have produced about
12 billion so that's more or less in the
same ballpark
it is going to have to come from
taxation which means from all of us
but it also there is going to have to be
responsibility for individuals but it
has to be seen to be just and fair and
to meet the values we want as a society
it's no use saying we can do it on the
cheap because we can't
and so the report makes it clear here
are the values here's the implication of
the values here's the need for the
national Covenant
and links in to other reports that have
been done over the last many years and
just to be clear Archbishop so you feel
that the
pardon I mean the point you're making in
the report is that this happens to all
of us at some point in our lives and so
this should be a collective societal
endeavor
do you think the burden should fall on
people's Estates perhaps harder under
States perhaps inherited Estates or on
General taxation or a mix it's a mix
it's always going to be a mix and if we
go back to some of the past examinations
of this uh there's a cap on what the
suggestion of a cap on what should be
spent by individuals those weren't done
by the church but there's been a lot of
thought going into this but as you say
it may sound like motherhood and apple
pie
but at least apple pie is eaten the
motherhood and apple pie as you call it
of the report
s and develops themes that have been
there for over 20 years not in any one
party but have never been implemented
and Archbishop what would you say to
people that might say to you this isn't
your job this is not your job this is a
political leadership issue not a
religious leadership issue I would say
caring for people is very much my job
it's very much the the role of the
church and is taught us in every
religious tradition and in humanism and
is very much what Christ says and also
in the report you also say we must value
those who provide care paid and unprayed
in Practical terms I think what you'll
say in there is that you'd like to see
care workers paid more
care work has to be seen as a valuable
profession in its own right with a
career structure and the possibility of
development and growth and higher pay
and carers should not be there on the
Jeep what they're doing is essential we
don't say you know oh well we could get
away with paying nurses the bare minimum
wage
we don't say that because we know Health
matters
we do say it too often with people we
depend on but care carers it's a very
skilled job so you feel that they should
have a pay more aligned to nursing and
nurse and others in the caring
profession I think there should be the
development of a career in care where
you can progress get more qualifications
if you want work part-time work
full-time in as there are in so many
other areas of that are essential to our
common life and Archbishop if I may I'm
going to ask you
um something about another subject
because in the report you talk about
ending discrimination
but you've also been accused yourself of
discrimination against LGBT people and I
think there was a demonstration outside
yesterday where you went to talk to
people now it's 10 years ago today that
same-sex marriage bill was passed in the
House of Commons and here we are with
the church refusing to back gay marriage
you've personally refused to bless
same-sex marriage is their own issue of
credibility here that on the one hand
you're asking for inclusion and better
care for the elderly and people in our
communities
in society whilst on the other hand
you're discriminating against the LGBT
community that's what people might think
that's what people might think I accept
that's what they people might think and
that's
uh they weren't talking about care last
night but the people outside
demonstrating I went out there there's
been Bradshaw MP and Janos and leading
and Peter tatchell and um they were
saying that we got it wrong as a church
there are two things there first we have
made
huge step which is to say that if
someone is married in a civil marriage
equal marriage to someone of their own
gender
um same-sex marriage that they can come
to church and be have that married
marriage recognized and thanked for and
dedicate themselves to God and seek
God's blessing in their lives
and that's something that we've never
done before and it's controversial
um I'm getting equal amount of flack
from the other side about having
compromised traditional Christian
standards the second thing is the
Archbishop of York who's going to use
these resources that we've published
and I uh and I'm not
are on exactly the same page we welcome
these resources strongly but we have
slightly different jobs I'm also
the senior Bishop in one sense or
another the first among equals around
the whole world where in many countries
there are very very different attitudes
and my job is the Pastoral Care and to
care for and support people in 165
countries with every sort of culture and
language if you were not the fast among
equals would you personally bless
same-sex marriages if you were not I
support the use of these resources so I
uh it's they they Bless the people in
Saints there's a marriage for you not to
be able to do what you personally would
like to do then
no I accept that it's part of my role
it's just the way it is but you accept
that there's a conflict there that's
uncomfortable yeah it's not comfortable
but you know
the church is deeply divided over this
issue every Global Church is
and the church in this country is in
every denomination we have to face that
reality is news wishing the world was
other than it is and just finally at
this weekend we had news of the
coronation ah yes
um you will conduct the service it's the
fast coronation in seven decades it's
going to be a moment of huge
significance for our country
what's your hopes for the coronation and
also is it an opportunity to heal some
Rifts
I think it is
an opportunity I'm thinking of the Rifts
over the that have divided our society
over the last many years
my hope is that it will be an enormous
celebration that people will get
together on watch the service on the
Telly lots of churches and Cathedrals by
the way will have it on that on the
Sunday they'll have parties and get
together on the Monday as is planned
that they will go out and do a day of
volunteering to help each other for the
common good so huge party weekend fun
together
I hope too that it will celebrate our
past
our history this wonderful Nation
the great history we have it will
recognize both the challenges and the
joys of the present and it will give
people hope for a future as a United
Country working together and where we
differ doing so well and not with
hostility